is this the end of President erdogan's
era
or maybe the start of another Victory
against the odds
the president trying to sound confident
even though he knows he's in a fight for
his long political life
he has recently been handing out pay
Rises presents and food today he gave
money to children
except for this one his grandson who got
a slap in the face
around him the voters who've shown such
loyalty who consider him a strong
defender of both country and faith
I support our president
is first he helped women like me get a
job and secondly I got an education
according to my religious beliefs
across the country erdogan's rival was
squeezing his way through raucous crowds
greeted as a hero Kamal kilistarolu
voted in his home city of Ankara
and so in this crowded chaotic sweaty
School room Kamal Chris tharulu is just
casting his vote the question is how
many of his country men and women will
do the same could this be the day when
President erdogan's 20-year rule comes
to an end
Mr uru looked upbeat his support is here
balancing hopes of Victory with growing
expectation he told them spring was
coming
the old
human rights
we need peace now so it's very important
for us and we are so happy for this day
this is like the rebirth of the Republic
for us because we've been so oppressed
for 20 something years
in the areas devastated by February's
earthquake there were few schools to use
as polling stations but turnout was high
here and across the whole country
oh
this is a close race if neither
candidate gets more than 50 of the votes
then we'll have a runoff election in a
fortnight a divided nation May yet have
to wait for a sense of resolution